[Musique]
france d'amour j'ai tellement aimé votre
émission de radio à la chaîne musicale
de radio-canada ce parce que c'est un
bilan 35 ans de carrière à quelque sorte
que vous commencez par le début parce
que vous avez grandi à mont rolland
vous avez été adopté par une famille de
ce type à des artistes finalement ce qui
est intéressant c'est quand ils m'ont
adopté
il ya un petit carton avec des
informations sur ma mère mon nom
d'adoption dans mon nom à ce moment là
c'est paul de grand pré ma mère a 27 ans
et sa clique de crise le piéton est ce
qui est fascinant c'est qu'elle est
musicienne
donc je sais pas si c'est ça et le père
vient la grande bretagne c'est un
ingénieur donc proche de l'ecosse donc
peut-être les taches de rousseur mon
petit côté fifi brindacier
ça vient peut-être de ce test génétique
était musicienne de quoi votre mère
biologique le savez vous sont ainsi pas
spécialement marqué musiciens oui je me
considère déjà comme des amis en
écoutant votre émission musicale la
marche ont décroché lorsque vous dites à
14 ans pavoisé me prête sa guitare et
puis là en cinq heures
bompard vient du travail je connais les
chansons je sais jouer
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec cet
instrument le pendant ces quelques
heures
mais si c'est vrai qu'ici c'est étonnant
j'ai pris la guitare il va être au début
de l'après midi est effectivement car
mon père est arrivé à 5h à mettre un
petit peu pompette d'ailleurs et non
mais la phase qui fait il comprend
tellement proskurin musique quoi de 12,6
salimo jamais vu jouer d'un instrument y
sommes allés se trouvait dans la maison
on avait une vieille mandoline gosset
haamene mon arrière-grand-père qu'il n'y
avait rien à faire avec ça qu'ils le
savent et jean-michel vais jouer
vraiment en cinq ans je sais pas ce que
c'est pas si je me suis ça a été ça a
été fusionnelle avec la guitare je me
suis mis à jouer de la guitare mais pas
seulement des petits accords je me
réalise des accords barre et puis ça
c'est pas si ça a été
ça a été un coup de foudre vraiment
[Musique]
france d'amour dans la chanson vivante
sur votre deuxième album vous chantez
qu'au début de votre carrière vous avez
dormi dans des études de guitare donc
france d'amour il ya deux études guitare
la boj d'apporter sa donc les modèles
électriques avec la petite le petit
tapir minou puis la version acoustique
c'était sec et dans quel modèle version
électrique
oui c'était la guitare c'est quand même
tout est assez grand ça fait s'affaisser
recueille un peu mais oui il n'y avait
pas ces deux changements rappel c'est à
saint-joachim tourelles c'était en
gaspésie et on était trop il n'y avait
pas assez de lits pot de chambre et moi
j'ai dormi dans mon 15 hectares dans ce
mode la saladelle exactement vous entre
jean traces asador assez bien il faut
dire il faudrait qu'à cette époque là je
dormais n'importe où tu une vieille
chaise un divan lit avec les sprints qui
ressortent je pouvais dormait
d'importance à changer évidemment
[Musique]
vous avez dit que vous avez un
baccalauréat en boucane et une maîtrise
en gauche oh oui comment vous avez fait
pour survivre dans un monde dans celui
le monde du rap fermé ouais c'est vrai
que là la tournée des bars là au début
des fêtes dans les années 80 c'était pas
facile mais mais les musiciens était
protecteur puis j'avais mon amoureux
dans le groupe donc j'étais un peu
protégé par mes musiciens
mais ça ça reste que tu te fais une
carapace
ça reste que tout une carapace se
comment répondre faire affaire avec du
monde pompette des gauchos se commet pas
les provoquer aussi se commentent
esquivé en douceur après tout ces trucs
là très pratique
après avoir interprété esmeralda dans
notre dame de paris
vous avez enregistré un album avec
robert et jean jacques goldman c'est une
aventure qui vous a laissé un peu me
figue mi raisin ben écoute c'est dommage
mais en même temps je lis il faut savoir
aussi que mon fils était jeune à
l'époque puis avait besoin de savoir et
la relation extraordinaire
j'ai choisi mon mot que j'ai avec mon
fils en ce moment me donne raison
d'avoir des bêtes partie la bad est
revenu pour parce que y était au début
si si commencé l'école y avait besoin de
sa maman donc ça c'est une des raisons
principales c'est pourquoi je suis
revenu
france d'amour je vous souhaite un
excellent retour sur scène et une bonne
fête des mères dimanche si gentil merci
oui moi aussi je vais en profiter bonne
fête à toutes les mamans du monde entier
vous envoie de l'amour du courage
1la l'instinct maternel à cette force
herculéenne qui fait qu'on ferait tout
pour nos petits bonne fête des mamans
merci beaucoup
richier
de chanter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ciao
[Musique]
là